and go look new hook come here you can
do the carousel that's Jennifer Lopez
showing off her skills on the pole in
the new trailer for her upcoming flick
hustlers hustlers now in a new interview
with vulture the film's writer and
director Loreen stuff Arya is revealing
how JLo prepped for her role as a
scamming stripper named Ramona I loved
his character even recruiting her fiance
Alex Rodriguez to help her research
deceit and rap quote she and Alex went
and visited a strip club and she was
able to give me some insights yeah you
heard that right
we even went to a strip club together
hard yes we did really yeah yeah now did
you I said I have to go he's like let's
go the actress first dished on her in
Alex's strip club outing during a stop
by Apple music beats one in April it was
cool you know and we talked to some some
of the girls and got some info I watched
you know you know I'm just you know just
soaking it all in soaking up the
atmosphere watching you know how to do
stuff authentically and unreal and it
was fun and Jennifer admitted a rod was
pretty pumped when she took on the role
oh he was very excited he was very
excited he was like oh yes what do you
need to know he do some research but the
hard work didn't stop there when et
recently caught up with Jennifer she
revealed just how physically demanding
the part was learning pole dancing was
probably one of the most challenging
things I've ever done for a film my arm
is still recovering and my back so yeah
I would say that was the hardest thing I
ever did but it was worth it the highly
anticipated film was inspired by the
viral New York Magazine article about
former strip club employees who banded
together to turn the tables on their
Wall Street clients when I was a kid
though I was one at work with animals
I was close and features an all-star
cast including Constance Wu keke palmer
Lily Reinhardt
Julia Stiles and cardi B to name a few I
love this story it's a really gritty New
York story women at the forefront just
real life the thing like actresses dream
of is in this movie and to be able to
produce a tenth star and it was real
special